[Musique]
Dogora la puissante oeuvre d'Étienne
Perruchon interprété par les jeunes de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
[Musique]
les élèves des classes de la communauté
d'agglomération ont fait raisonner le
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
samedi 1er juillet une consécration pour
les jeunes chanteurs c'était bien on a
et ils ont créé une bonne expérience
c'était ma première expérience et
c'était la meilleure ils ont bien créé
le spectacle on a bien chanté
il y avait des moments lorsque j'aimais
trop parce que en répétition il y avait
pas tout le monde et là ça m'a avec tout
le monde c'était magnifique ce concert
était le fruit de longs mois de travail
et de préparation réalisée avec
l'Association pour la musique à
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines l'occasion
pour les enfants de présenter leur
performance à leurs proches oui je suis
trop fière de ma fille et c'était ma
première expérience avec elle et ça me
donnait trop de fiertés ça me fait les
langues dans les yeux là je suis trop
fière d'elle et merci pour l'école déjà
pour toute l'équipe qui a participé pour
réussir cette événement et l'opéra des
enfants est organisée depuis 2003 par la
pmsq le but de l'association rendre
accessible la musique classique au
population des quartiers défavorisés un
événement dont tout le monde ressort
gagnant un concert comme ça c'est une
fierté pour tout le monde et surtout
pour les enfants et pour leur famille
parce qu'on a des familles qui vont
rarement dans des salles de spectacle et
là les parents viennent ils sont
émerveillés parce que font leurs enfants
et ils sont justement émerveillés parce
que c'est des choses qui méritent le
respect c'est absolument incroyable les
enfants donnent donnent de même ils sont
complètement investis dans le
dans leur champ et c'est absolument
phénoménal un moment hors du temps ça
lui est par un tonnerre
d'applaudissement Paris réussi pour les
jeunes chanteurs de 50 ans en Yvelines
[Applaudissements]